muito boa noite com o cabelo branco
button e 10 mil anos
[Música]
é quando eu era criança e acho que maior
parte de nós no nosso sistema
educacional
quando a gente fazia uma prova ou alguns
de nós ainda faz algumas provas a gente
eu me deparava com a seguinte imagem das
minhas provas ou minha resposta estava
certa ou minha resposta está errado eu
cresci me formei e hoje vivemos todos
nós do mundo injete transformação por
causa da conectividade e por causa das
novas gerações que muitos estão aqui por
um acaso
isso está gerando no mundo e no nosso
planeta uma transformação numa
velocidade exponencial e dependendo da
perspectiva que a gente enxerga a gente
está enxergando muitos sofrimentos
primeiro olhando para os indivíduos a
olhar para os indivíduos
eu vejo o sofrimento por exemplo em
inúmeras pesquisas mostrando o nível de
desembaraçamento de muitas pessoas com
seus trabalhos índice em torno de 70 a
80 chegando a 90% de gente infeliz com o
que está fazendo e não usando nenhum
terço do seu potencial
tem várias causas mas muitos sofrimentos
de acabam acontecendo do número grande
de consumo de remédios de tarja preta
por exemplo
ou mesmo o aumento de obesidade consumo
de álcool e drogas
isso são indicadores claros que tem algo
errado agora saindo dos indivíduos indo
para o coletivo para a nossa sociedade
para o nosso planeta também a gente vê
sofrimento
olhando por exemplo o meio ambiente a
gente tem problemas seríssimos
aquecimento global degradação ambiental
ou mesmo nesse instante
nesse minuto quantas guerras estão
acontecendo nesse momento
nesse momento que a gente está aqui e
agora tem gente puxando a arma um pro
outro e matando também temos problemas
gravíssimos
do ponto de vista coletiva
isso quer dizer tanto do ponto de vista
individual quanto do ponto de vista de
coletivo é como se a gente tivesse nesse
momento uma grande prova na nossa frente
uma grande questão uma grande pergunta
como é possível a gente diminuir o
sofrimento de indivíduos e do coletivo e
o que eu venho percebendo é que na
verdade a resposta
a solução dessa equação não é focar no
indivíduo ou no coletivo é focar no
indivíduo
na verdade mais do que focar e caminhar
nu e é dançar no é entre indivíduo e
coletivo vamos à primeira os indivíduos
há sete anos atrás eu comecei uma
jornada inicia e tive a honra de começar
um conceito chamado eu prendedor smu
o empreendedorismo é um processo de
reflexão de propósito
o mapeamento de possibilidades e como
colocar esse propósito em prática
na verdade esse conceito surgiu até
fruto do meu sofrimento
um dos indivíduos que estava sofrendo
era eu
durante 14 anos trabalham em
multinacionais na área de marketing e
fui muito feliz e cresci e aprendi
bastante nessas empresas e nessa minha
carreira chegando ao cargo de diretor de
marketing da américa latina
chic estava indo bem
o status só que um vazio muito grande
dentro de mim eu olhava pro futuro da
minha carreira e não era bem aquilo que
eu queria fazer o resto da minha vida ea
grande pergunta era o que eu queria
fazer da minha vida eu não sabia
responder essa pergunta então começou um
processo de busca para tentar responder
essa pergunta eu fiz vários processos de
auto conhecimento
todo mundo que indicavam alguma coisa eu
vamos lá vamos fazer e também comecei a
fazer coisas e experimentar coisas nessa
jornada eu acabei fundando a rede o
ubuntu de empreendedorismo com o
objetivo de apoiar com o propósito de
apoiar milhares de pessoas milhões de
pessoas a refletirem sobre seus
propósitos refletir sobre o que elas
estão fazendo aqui e como colocar isso
em prática porque na verdade o vazio que
eu estava sentindo
na verdade não é uma exclusividade mim
olhava pro meu lado e muita gente estava
nessa situação ea isso me motivou a
fundar a rede o ponto de
empreendedorismo como é que eu podia
usar os meus palentólogos a serviço de
mexer com essa realidade
de novo é uma coisa ea outra nessa
história a gente veio já apoiando
milhares de pessoas e vários projetos
várias iniciativas estão surgindo
incríveis
hoje em dia e eu além de ser marqueteiro
porque continua sendo o marqueteiro
eu também sou escritor coach palestrante
facilitador e palhaço
tudo isso junto às vezes você pode olhar
falar nossa tadinho tá perdido né
na verdade o que dá liga é a palavra e
ea liga vem do meu propósito porque
todas essas atividades fazem sentido
dentro da minha direção vamos agora
olhar para o coletivo
no caso do coletivo quando a gente
comece a empreender o nosso propósito a
gente começa a caminhar em direção ao
nosso propósito
a gente começa a se juntar com outras
pessoas onde começa a se relacionar e
porquê porque os problemas que a gente
enfrenta na nossa jornada são muito
complexos e cada vez mais complexos e
para a gente resolver tais problemas a
gente vai precisar se conectar com o
outro porque a minha inteligência só não
resolve mais resolver pra esse problema
eu preciso da inteligência do outro eo
cruzamento dessas inteligências que vão
ajudar a resolver esses problemas há
sete anos atrás quando fundei a rede
ubuntu começou comigo
apoiado pela minha esposa jogo só que à
medida que o tempo o tempo foi passando
veio a talhe veio a nina veio a mo e
mais e mais pessoas foram se juntando e
chegou lá para 2013
eu fui parar no hospital com crise de
ansiedade e stress
como assim eu estava fazendo meu
trabalho com propósito minha segundas
feiras já eram estava curtindo já não
era um desastre como é que eu fui parar
no hospital
tudo bem eu estava trabalhando muito
mesmo era um sinal claro que precisava
mudar o modelo para trabalhar um pouco
menos mas principalmente eu estava no
hospital por uma crise emocional uma
crise de ansiedade porque naquela altura
éramos já mais ou menos umas 15
pessoas ea gente e eu especificamente
estava morrendo de medo de perder o
controle
eu fui treinando para ter controle
naquela altura a gente estava aumentando
o número dos projetos o número de
pessoas e eu olhando para aquilo e
falando cara de fábio saci organizar e
aí a gente estava começando a replicar o
modelo que eu tinha aprendido a minha
vida inteira chefe o chefinho e peão
tudo bem que a gente inventava os nomes
bonitos né os organogramas xix e tal
linha pontilhada pra cá pra lá e tal mas
no final das contas era chefe o chefe
piá e olhava e outras pessoas estavam
comigo olhava para aquele modelo falou
cara mas não é isso
isso num órgão com o que a gente está
fazendo ea grande pergunta era o que a
gente ia fazer do ponto de vista
coletivo como é que a gente ia se
organizar
foi nesse momento que eu encontrei a
teoria de redes e eu comecei a
identificar que existia outros jeitos da
gente se organizar na verdade existia um
jeito que na verdade a natureza nos
ensina muito porque somos parte da
natureza são ecossistemas
a rede ponto chama rede portanto a gente
não podia ser outra coisa senão um
ecossistema colaborativo de pessoas e
organizações voltado para o
empreendedorismo como é que a gente pode
criar organizações que convivam com a
distribuição para a gente criar juntos
de maneira distribuída e orgânica em ao
mesmo tempo na hora que identifica o que
eu preciso entregar no final da linha a
gente consegue automaticamente se
organizar em papéis em hierarquia e aí
sim entregar aquilo que a gente precisa
entregar como é que eu crio uma
organização um ecossistema que conviva
com eficiência e
eficácia com organicidade e processos
definidos
existe formas de a gente se relacionar e
criar organizações para os tempos
modernos que a gente está vivendo a
revolução industrial já foi
não precisamos de novas formas de se
organizar e faz sete anos que a gente
vem experimentando aí novos modelos da
gente se organizar para a gente conviver
com e fazer uma coisa e fazer outra
inovar é e entregá lo agora como eu
falei não basta só olhar para o
indivíduo e do coletivo é preciso dançar
entre essas duas coisas
e nessa jornada eu encontrei uma
filosofia lindíssima chamada o ubuntu
na verdade eu conheci essa palavra ainda
como executivo
uma terapeuta minha dessas abordagens de
autoconhecimento que eu falei para vocês
que eu fiz
uma delas indicou um filme chamado em
minha terra e nesse filme tinha a
palavra o ponto e eu me apaixonei pela
palavra não tem um caderninho falei
algum dia vou usar essa palavra alguma
coisa na minha vida
anos depois quando foi fundada a
organização tava lá é o ponto
o que é o boom do ubuntu é
interdependência relacionamento
colaboração humanidade solidariedade é
uma filosofia africana que inclusive
nelson mandela utilizou e muitos anos de
sua jornada
é uma filosofia que alguns anos atrás eu
fui numa conferência mundial o ponto em
lisboa e aprendi que o ponto é a
construção da sua individualidade dentro
de uma comunidade e eu achei aquilo
incrível porque é a dança entre o
indivíduo eo coletivo não é o indivíduo
pelo indivíduo e não é o coletivo pelo
coletivo
são as duas coisas pra você poder
existir dentro de uma comunidade você
precisa construir a sua individualidade
você precisa ter noção do seu papel
daquilo para que você veio e começar a
se relacionar a partir disso de maneira
independente
portanto para resolver aqueles problemas
complexos que eu falei no início da
minha fala em violência sofrimentos
degradação ambiental desengajamento de
indivíduos com seus trabalhos
o caminho ou melhor a dança tá entre
focarmos nos indivíduos olhar pra dentro
refletir sobre quem você é o que você
está fazendo
e também como a gente está se
organizando como é que a gente está se
relacionando como é que a gente está
construindo projetos juntos para poder
implementar e executar esses propósitos
que a gente está falando
como eu falei há sete anos atrás
a rede ponto nasceu como um grande
movimento
o movimento de o prendedor smo para que
mais e mais pessoas efetivamente comecem
a olhar pra dentro
refletir sobre a relação e como fazer
projetos e iniciativas a partir disso na
verdade é um movimento de conexão
o movimento de conexão com você mesmo
com o outro e com algo maior e portanto
ao invés de conexão eu gostaria de
chamar de espiritualidade
eu tenho convicção que o caminho pra
gente cada vez mais seguir em resolver
os problemas complexos que a gente está
vivendo na sociedade
é a espiritualidade e não
espiritualidade do ponto de vista
religioso
a espiritualidade do ponto de vista de
conexão conexão consigo mesmo e com o
outro e com algo maior
vamos dançar eu sou porque você é você é
porque nós somos muito obrigado
[Aplausos]